this small village temple some 60
kilometers outside the city of chennai
is a symbol of india's battle to
retrieve its stolen antiques
one of its most prized statues a bronze
somas kanda was looted four decades ago
the man leading the fight to return it
is amateur art detective vijay kumar
this is a temple that was pillaged of
its
precious bronzes
sometime in the past 40 years
we were lucky that it was documented in
1916 it was a book uh that was published
in 1916 that had a single photograph of
a samas khanda that was photographed
when inside this temple
somehow found its way now in the asian
civilization's museum singapore
if this bronze comes back this temple
will get back its old glory and the
villagers will be doubly happy that
their gods have come home
the temple now has protected status and
the villagers say it's the heart of
their community
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
vijay says his team came across the
bronze around eight years ago and traced
it back to this village seven kudel the
museum in singapore has not responded to
requests for comment
bloomberg is unable to independently
verify the origins of the statue
tracking down india's stolen relics is a
global task
this buddha statue went missing around
two decades ago from a pilgrimage site
in the state of bihar
london based art detective chris
marileno worked with vijay's team to
find it in italy and return it to the
indian authorities in milan
working with volunteers from across the
world vijay has helped to seize hundreds
of antiques from major museums and
auction houses
our main purpose of doing this is to
stop the industrial organized scale
plunder of our heritage treasures shared
heritage of india indian art has been
targeted by smugglers going back 150
years
from 1972 to 2012 india had recovered
only 19 antiques
now vijay says the number is over 250
many of them due to his help but he
would like to see more efforts to stop
them being sold off in the first place
i think if the government comes up with
some sort of
like a finder's fee
or a nominal reward because the actual
finder doesn't get paid these million
dollar
sums that fetch that market
i think we can put a stop to these
precious mutis that have been smuggled
out and sold to
billionaires to house their bedrooms and
swimming pools
the indian government says it's working
hard to bring back antiques from around
the world and is developing an antiques
database to combat trafficking under a
national mission launched in 2007.
the work however is still in progress
[Music]
you